[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue pour ce nouveau
numéro de mode d'emploi votre magazine
consacré à l'emploi et à la formation
professionnelle
une édition consacrée au secteur
industriel tout de suite le sommaire
dépasser le phénomène de
désindustrialisation grâce à l'industrie
4.0 c'est le défi que tentent de relever
plusieurs entreprises notamment grâce
aux nouvelles technologies
illustration avec la multinationale
américaine rockwell automation et
l'alliance renault nissan se former aux
métiers industriels au ca fille de
montigny le bretonneux
cette école de la chambre de commerce et
d'industrie d'île de france propose
notamment une filière électronique et
robotique mêlant mécanique et numérique
enfin découverte de la pme r mattel
implantée à trappes depuis sa création
en 2002 sa spécialité la fabrication de
cartes électroniques automobile
aéronautique énergie ou électronique
voilà plusieurs activités qui font de
saint quentin en yvelines un territoire
d'industrie le secteur compte près de
700 entreprises et emplois emploie près
de 23000 personnes sur l'agglomération
une filière en pleine évolution avec le
développement de l'industrie du futur
c'est le cas notamment chez rockwell
automation et au technocentre renault de
guyancourt regarder automatisée une
usine industrielle à partir de plusieurs
types d'équipements l'activité de
l'entreprise américaine rockwell
automation des systèmes de plus en plus
digitalisées notamment avec cet outil
destiné à gérer toute une usine
d'incinération et de revalorisation
d'ordures ménagères
c'est un système qui est en revendant au
niveau matériel qui en cas de panne
matériel type disque dur ou
mémoire ou cartes mères permettent la
disponibilité du système
de continuer à fonctionner coté à la
bourse de new york avec un chiffre
d'affaires de 6,7 milliards de dollars
au coût et l'automation a installé sa
filiale française à voisins le
bretonneux leader mondial dans son
secteur d'activité elle bascule
aujourd'hui vers l'industrie 4.0 c'est
un paquet d'informations qui a passé de
lusine jusqu'au sommet de l'entreprise
lorsqu'on appelle les erp etc pour
diffuser ses informations et données in
fine et la bonne information à la bonne
personne au bon moment pour prendre les
bonnes décisions au niveau de la gestion
de lusine et donc de la productivité de
masina même transformation pour
l'alliance renault nissan l'usiné
automobile du futur se construit au
technocentre de guyancourt
plusieurs nouveaux outils automatiques
pour améliorer la productivité avec
notamment des robots collaboratif qui on
va venir voir ces les coutures sont bien
placés le contrôle après on va voir si à
l'instar de la porte qu'on allait les
bons caractère qui sont sur les poignets
l'industrie se transforment et évoluent
sur saint quentin en yvelines
l'agglomération a obtenu en novembre
2018 la reconnaissance territoire
d'industrie par le ministère de
l'économie et des finances
l'école connecté au futur de l'industrie
c'est la promesse du cfi de montigny le
bretonneux
c'est le principal centre de formation
aux métiers industriels de saint quentin
en yvelines
il propose plusieurs diplômes en allant
du crp au bac + 5 parmi les quatre
filières proposées celle de
l'électronique et de la robotique
découvertes sur des images de patrick
jacques de dixmude
[Musique]
nous sommes avec maya borie bonjour
responsables de la filière électronique
et robotique alors qu'est ce que c'est
qu'est ce qu'on a devant nous la à baden
devons-nous nous avons les
deux cartes électroniques qu'ils sont
développé par les étudiants donc une des
sept cartes électroniques c'est une
carte en fait qu'ils aient développé
pour les systèmes embarqués et aussi
avec un petit display qui dans l
afficheur du texte qui est sous cette
carte est de l'autre côté nous avons un
robot c'est en fait un combo qui
s'appelle u13 l'écho beau petit comme ça
qu'ils sont cons qui travaillent en
collaboration avec les humains au
plupart en général il est de 12 à
appliquer les petites cartes à lettres
électronique
donc voilà soit davantage sa faux dur
donc ce sont des projets qui ont été
développés à travers les formations qui
sont présentes dans la filière
électronique de robotique alors qu'est
ce que vous proposez comme formation le
sco donc nous nous avons les formations
pratiquement en apprentissage donc
niveau bac + 2 donc c'est en bts
systèmes numériques options options
électronique communicant
nous avons une licence systèmes
embarqués et nous avons une formation
qui s'appelle manager un système
informatique et robotique et quelles
compétences on acquiert dans ces
formations
donc c'est long des niveaux des
effusions donc par exemple niveau bac +
2 c'est ils vont acquérir les
compétences de réparer une carte
électronique cela de choisir certains
petits composants de la carte
électronique niveau licence il va être
capable de travailler sur les systèmes
temps réel la programmation java de
également de travailler sous les cartes
électroniques plutôt les cartes
didier vraiment les systèmes embarqués
et nous avons aussi la formation qui
niveau bac + 5
mais la dja site informatique et
robotique la cdg niveau un petit pot
gestion de projets manager de projet et
aussi de développeurs d un système
complexe
quels sont les débouchés quels métiers
peuvent exercer les personnes qui ont
terminé cette formation donc ça peut
être un technicien en électronique
ça peut être un assistant en de
l'ingénieur et comme j'ai dit ça dépend
aussi des niveaux c'est aussi les
développeurs un développeur en
électronique
soit aux systèmes embarqués merci
beaucoup et je vous propose maintenant
d'aller en immersion dans un cours de
travaux pratiques projets industriels
et nous rejoignons adrien que l'essence
bonjour bonjour alors vous suivez une
formation de manager des systèmes
informatique et robotique au sefi de
montigny-le-bretonneux alors est-ce que
vous pouvez m'expliquer ce que vous êtes
en train de faire
alors là en fait je suis en train de
souder une carte informatique donc pour
le projet on doit faire une carte donc
pour pour mon entreprise et du coup ça
nécessite quelques petites soudure alors
comment se déroule cette formation alors
c'est une formation en trois ans enfin
en deux ou en trois ans dépendantes
après soit après une licence soit après
un bts et du coup ça va deux ans
d'alternance en robotique aibo
l'informatique on mêle en fait des
compétences industrielles typiquement
industriels puisque cela vous fait de la
soudure c'est ça et la compétence aussi
informatique et programmation
informatique
voilà c'est ça donc en fait là en fait
ce qu'on va faire c'est surtout des
prototypes et on va développer donc tout
ça avec l'informatique pour la caisse
que se développer concrètement à quoi ça
va servir
c'est une carte d'interface alors en
fait ça va servir à l'entreprise en
train de développer une robot qui va qui
soude en fait des tout petits composants
typiquement des microprocesseurs et des
choses comme ça et du coup il ya besoin
de plusieurs cartes bancaires face entre
des entrées numériques
voilà analogique à un ordinateur qui
pilote le tour personnellement c'est
quoi votre projet professionnel et quel
métier vous souhaiteriez exercé après
sept formateurs
personnellement ça de puteaux ingénieur
en robotique du coup donc ça peut être
plus j'ai pas d'idée spécifique là tout
de suite mais ça peut être intégrateur
de robots dans une usine par exemple où
ça peut être juste de développer
dans une start-up un petit robot
collaboratif ou des choses comme ça bon
alors je vais peut-être m'essayer à la
soudure donc vous venez prendre voilà le
faire vounet l'appliquer vert attention
le film vaut le field est un fond de
remontée ben oui effectivement il faut
voilà appliquées ou d'un petit on change
un peu sur le côté vous êtes moment sur
l'extrémité de la pale fin du ce est
surcoté la wii on voit que ça devient
très gai lamoureux voilà vous enlevez
les temps et voilà adrien que l'essence
merci beaucoup pour cette démonstration
et ses explications et si vous souhaitez
plus d'informations sur le cfi de
montigny le bretonneux vous pouvez vous
rendre sur le site internet qui
s'affiche en bas de l'écran s'est
fissuré formation.fr restons dans le
domaine de l'électronique c'est la
spécialité derma tels ces pme créée en
2002 est installé dans la zone
d'activité industrielle les bruyères à
trappes
elle fabrique des cartes électroniques
pour différents secteurs d'activité avec
patrick jacques de dixmude nous sommes
allés à la rencontre des employés de
cette entreprise ferme at elle est une
pme industrielles installées et créer à
saint quentin en yvelines en 2002 c'est
une entreprise spécialisée dans la
production de cartes électroniques et
nous sommes avec valérie verbraeken
directrice commerciale de cette
entreprise bonjour bonjour alors est-ce
que vous pouvez nous présenter votre
activité
nous sommes sous traitant électronique
donc et nous avons deux pôles
d'activités dont la conception de la
carte électronique la ceao plus
effectivement l'assemblage de cartes
électroniques mais également du câblage
filaire
voilà et nous travaillons pour des
grands donneurs d'ordre aujourd'hui qui
se situe dans deux domaines d'activités
principaux l'automobile avec le groupe
valeo
donc ça c'est représente une certaine
part importante de notre chiffre
d'affaires mais également l'aéronautique
ou là on retrouve des clients comme
airbus ou safran vous avez une trentaine
de salariés c'est ça c'est ça tout à
fait 37 de charles arié pour un chiffre
d'affaires d'environ 2 millions d'euros
par an alors avant d'aller retrouver
ludovic n'useront dans l'atelier une
deux dernières questions sur la
stratégie industrielle que vous adoptez
ici chez armateurs alors aujourd'hui
effectivement notre stratégie
commerciale s'ils d
l'opm ans mon accès développer trouver
de nouveaux partenaires de nouveaux
clients parce qu'effectivement les
clients c'est aussi des partenaires et
donc ça dans douze d'autres domaines ça
peut être le médical objets connectés
on travaille aussi bien ils descendent
recherche et des pme des start-up aussi
voilà moi c'est mon axe de recherche
c'est effectivement et on va derrière
vous de grosses machines je suppose que
il ya beaucoup d'investissements qui
sont faits chez vous oui tout à fait
donc c'est en permanence on doit être à
la pointe de la technologie
donc là c'est des investissements qu'on
a cessé nous machine de placement
automatique donc pour la réalisation de
nos cartes souvent cms est complexe
on essaye effectivement d'investir à
chaque fois pour être au top et pouvoir
satisfaire les demandes des clients
valérie verbraeken merci beaucoup et
maintenant direction l'atelier à la
rencontre de ludovic michaux
[Musique]
et nous avons rejoint ludovic nous
jugerons bonjour bonjour vous êtes le
responsable de la production cher mattel
alors poids différentes activités autour
de nous qu'est ce qui se passe ici
alors ici en fait on fait du câblage de
cartes donc on va recevoir des pcb nu
donc comme on peut voir ici on n'a aucun
composant qui sont montés et le principe
c'est justement de la livrer un pc des
fonctionnels et avec les composants tous
câblée dessus et bien vérifier contrôler
et sa part cheikh clients après alors
qu'est-ce qu'ils sont pas celles par
exemple derrière nous on voit plein de
fils
voilà c'est ça donc là ça c'est une
autre partie saas avec toute la partie
filaire de la société on l'a en fait on
l activité c'est une partie filaire une
petite partie filaire est
essentiellement de la carte électronique
donc là on va faire toute la partie
contrôle soudure souvent les binoculaire
ici justement on est en train de déposer
là on va sérigraphié la carte on va
déposer de la pâte à braser ou après on
va venir déposer les composants sur la
pâte à braser vous avez quelle formation
pour faire cette activité
à l'origine j'avais fait un j'avais fait
un ca paix en apprentissage j'ai fait
ensuite un bep et un bac tourner
apprentissage et donc j'allais domaine
électronique
donc tu l électronique et l'a finalement
nous avons que des personnes qui ont
suivi des études en électronique
c'est ça c'est un métier industriel
finalement dans l'industrie il ya
beaucoup de choses qui évoluent et ça
évolue très rapidement
ouais comment votre métier se transforme
on tend sur la composante toujours de
plus en plus petit donc avant c'était
une technologie traversant donc on avait
des composants qui était monté sur une
face et qui était soudée de l'autre donc
ça c'était toute la partie traversante
ensuite on a eu les composants cms qui
soit arrivée donc c'est pour ça que
maintenant on arrive à faire des cartes
vraiment très petit avec énormément de
composants dessus ludovic nadon merci
beaucoup rmat elle recrute actuellement
un câble heures vous aurez comme mission
la préparation l'assemblage et la
vérification des composantes de cartes
électroniques pour toutes ces missions
vous serez formé au sein de l'entreprise
vous serez embauchés en cdi avec une
période d'essai et si vous êtes
intéressés vous pouvez postuler et
envoyez votre cv lettre de motivation à
l'adresse qui s'affiche en bas de
l'écran
ludovic point jugeront @ rmat elle.fr
c'est la fin de cette émission merci de
nous avoir suivis et à bientôt sur tv 78
[Musique]